[Musique]
et vous
et
il était le plus proche conseiller de
marine le pen communicants du fn comment
juge-t-il maintenant qu'il est redevenu
libre
la campagne présidentielle de son
ancienne patronne et que 10 du fmc
règlement de comptes
cette semaine nous déshabillons en tout
bien tout honneur florian philippot
bonjour florian philippot lourd la
dernière fois qu'on s'est vus vous aviez
un mot bureau au siège du front national
aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans ce café
où là vous n'avez plus le bureau alors
ça se passe comment cette nouvelle vie
c'est pas trop dur de renoncer à tout ça
ce qu'a fait d'abord ça toujours été un
peu mon bureau bis avant oui oui dans
mon bureau dit ah oui c'est un peu ça
pourrait demander aux patrons il vous le
dira parce que j'y reçois beaucoup de
monde mais c'est vrai que non
provisoirement vous avez raison je n'ai
plus gros mais j'ai quitté un bureau de
vice président du front national et
j'aurai bientôt mon bureau de président
des patriotes où il se passera beaucoup
de choses où ce sera très très sympa et
très dynamique et qu'est ce qui vous
manque le plus de votre ancienne vie au
front national de gens cons que j'y
voyais bien sûr parce que évidemment
quand on part sur une rupture politique
bon bah ça fait aussi des dégâts
personnel c'est à dire qu'il ya des gens
que bon il ya des gens que je n'aimais
pas je suis content de ne plus voir je
vous l'avouer mais il ya aussi je veux
pas rentrer là dedans mais mais mais il
ya aussi beaucoup de gens que j'aimais
beaucoup et marine le pen elle vous
manque
bah j'ai passé de belles années avec
marine le pen gelé j'ai travaillé
pendant huit ans avec elle les derniers
mois était compliqué ça vous a pas
échappé mais vraiment été compliqué mais
je ne renie pas les années que j'ai
passées parce que ce n'est pas mon style
et qu'est ce qui vous manque le moins à
l'oeuvre bas ce qui me manque le moins
c'était très très vrai les derniers mois
c'est que j'ai été obligé totalement de
contenir ma parole
or pour 1
responsables politiques un élu comme je
suis de ne pas pouvoir dire tout à fait
ce qu'on pense ou avoir peur à chaque
instant oui je vous donne un exemple
très simple quand j'étais je suis contre
la loi travail bon et j'ai été
manifestée avec les forains dans leur
camion début septembre
mais je ne pars une photo à la limite
sur sur les réseaux sociaux je pouvais
pas faire plus que ça or j'avais mille
choses à dire j'avais j'avais envie
envie mais parce que je parce qu'on
était dans un étang une période où au
sein du front national tout m'était
reprochés jusqu'à cette participation au
mouvement social contre la loi travail
et donc pour ne pas mettre d'huile sur
le feu
je faisais attention un peu à tout et
vous aviez peur c'est parce qu'ils
avaient peur c'est que j'avais pas envie
de créer le capharnaüm général dans le
mouvement mais tous et je vais avoir une
attitude à peu près responsable mais à
partir du moment où j'ai fait un
arbitrage je me suis dit soit tu
continues comme ça et tu va baisser la
tête sans arrêt alors tu finiras par
oublier de gaulle savait que je célèbre
je rends hommage au général de gaulle
tous les 9 novembre jour de sa de son
décès à colombes et il faudra mettre de
côté des velléités d'ouverture de
modernisation même de participation au
mouvement social parce que ça sera perçu
comme un gauchiste ou je ne sais quoi
soit tu relèves la tête c'est tu fais de
la politique avec les idées que tu aimes
et que tu défends et auquel tu crois et
j'ai fait ce choix là tout vous était
reproché aussi par marine le pen ne pas
nous laisser faire je te rarement marine
le pen elle-même qu'il faut le dire
qu'ils intervenaient nous mais c'est et
des cadres qui parfois intervenez
d'ailleurs de manière très grossière et
vulgaire sur les raies ou agressifs sur
les réseaux sociaux
ok on retrouvera les référents justement
il ya une image aoula effectivement ça a
été voilà les dissensions ont été
révélés c'est la fameuse rentrée
politique à bras chez début septembre
on est quelques jours avant votre départ
du fn et l'ambiance semble très lourdes
je vous propose de revoir quelques
images
[Musique]
m
ses rangs
voilà là avec nicolas bay est au bout de
la table laurent philippot d'habitude
elle est toujours à côté de lui et l'a
pas un regard il s'adresse pas la parole
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
voilà à laon musicale était pas mal
c'est effectivement de circonstance
alors là c'est pas seulement qu'elle
laisse faire c'est qu'on a l'impression
qu'elle vous boude ostensiblement
qu'est ce que c'est quoi la coulisse de
cette image non mais là ça paraît
évident et qu'effectivement bon bah moi
j'étais assis à côté du maire de drap
chez donc ça me va très bien parce qu'on
a beaucoup discuté pendant tout ce repas
c'est pas le bras chez le plus agréable
que j'ai vécu mais pourquoi pourquoi
parce qu'alors il faut savoir que dans
les coulisses ya effectivement le
discours de bras chez et qui écrit ce
jour-là par philippe olivier le beau
frère de marine le pen on y reviendra
qui est plutôt sur la ligne on va dire
identitaire comme nicolas bay à côté de
qui elle est à 6 c'est ça que ça montre
cette image c'est ça que vous comprenez
à ce moment là ou pas ce que ça dit moi
que ce que je comprends c'est que j'ai
eu il ya plein de gens qui sont là avec
qui je fais des photos qui m'accueille
très bien voilà les élus locaux le maire
etc
et puis à marine le pen louis qui ôte
ostensiblement me boude ou montre calais
qu'elle est très heureuse a discuté avec
nicolas bay moi ça m'atteint pas je ne
suis pas ça c'est un peu creux de
récréation quand même hein ou alors
court court tout court c'est à dire la
cour du roi ou en place c'est le
courtisan plus ou moins loin du roi ou
de la reine pour montrer qui est en
cours et qui ne l'est pas bonjour j'ai
horreur de ça moi c'est pas un message
politique mais c'est toujours un message
politique mais cela s'est effectivement
il ya il ya un choix peut-être de ligne
voilà ça aussi ça a contribué au voyage
et à la réflexion je me suis dit je fais
pas de la politique comme ça on nous
cherche peut-être un millier c'est être
le but je suis je passe largement au
dessus de tout ça parce que j'ai quand
même passé une belle journée malgré tout
parce que j'ai vu beaucoup de monde et
qu'on a beaucoup échangé mais j'ai un
désaccord avec le discours qu'il
prononçait qui est très identitaire et
on oublie la française oublié on oublie
le social on oublie même parfois dans le
la connotation je trouve que le couple
les mots ne sont plus identitaire que
républicains et moi ça me pose un
problème
même quand on parle d'immigration et
puis 2 je fais pas de la politique pour
savoir si tel jour je suis en cours ou
tel jour je ne le suis plus si on me
beau de tel jour
me boude pas l'autre jour alors faut
quand même se remettre dans le contexte
parce que on est là à un moment assez
crucial
vous avez lancé votre association les
patriots au lendemain de la
présidentielle
et on est là début septembre quelques
jours avant que marine le pen vous
retire votre délégation de responsables
de la stratégie de la communication
le lendemain vous partez vous propose de
revenir sur ce moment là sur ce que ça
signifie avec le journaliste du monde
olivier faille qui commente quelques
images
ah on m'a dit que j'étais vice-président
donc à rien bah écoutez je n'ai pas le
goût du ridicule et je n'ai jamais eu le
goût de ne rien faire
donc bien sûr je quitte le front
national et je prends acte de sa
décision ce n'est pas pour moi
objectivement une surprise
je respecte sa décision mais je conteste
formellement l'habillage en créant sa
propre association des patriotes
il savait que ça allait mal se passer
d'autant qu'il n'est pas prévenu marine
le pen de cette initiative
rétrospectivement il dit il refait le
match en dix ans elle aurait pu se
saisir de cet objet que j'avais créé les
patriotes pour travailler sur la
refondation du front national dans les
faits voilà il avait lancé un peu sa
petite structure
tout seul donc c'était compliqué pour
lui de rester au camp national et des
départs certains ont dit voilà la
rupture va venir nécessairement en fait
finie peau c'est quelqu'un qui parle
d'ambition pour lui-même qui l'a jamais
caché on lui demande s'il veut être un
jour candidat à la présidentielle il a
toujours dit et moi je ressens même en
2015 début 2015 dans marianne il avait
dit si on ne gagne pas en 2017 et bien
on verra le front national c'est entre
guillemets c'est qu'un instrument pour
le pouvoir
on verra si je resterai au pas au front
national filippo c'est que pendant cinq
ans entre 2012 et 2017 il a été le
conseiller presque exclusif de marine le
pen
tous les deux et contribuer tous les
deux vraiment presque à égalité à
définir la ligne du front national et il
a vu au fur et à mesure de la campagne
présidentielle de 2017 son influence
décroître et il s'est dit dans les
années à venir mais les mois à venir on
va vouloir de 1 me faire porter le
chapeau de la défaite en 2017 et la
ligne risque d'évoluer juristes ne pas
avoir la même influence qu auparavant
donc me certaine manière
la solution pour lui c'était quand même
de partir et pourquoi il a eu moins
d'influencé pendant la campagne
en fait il y eut un personnage qui est
revenu au cours de la campagne
présidentielle c'est philippe olivier le
beau frère de marine le pen qui l'a en
2016 est revenue vraiment dans le jeu de
manière très active et lui clairement
c'est quelqu'un de beaucoup plus sur
l'île beaucoup plus identitaire qui est
très tonique dans sa volonté de d'avoir
une position très très dur d'avoir un
verbe très haut presque un verbe un peu
comme plus proche de ce que pouvait
faire jean marie le pen est en fait son
influence et sait le faire on phélippeau
se sont affronté l'une et l'autre et
pour phélippeau ça a été on va dire
assez difficile à vivre
il n'arrivait pas à imposer sa ligne
comme avant et marine le pen elle aussi
n'a pas réussi vraiment à une synthèse
entre ces deux influences c'est de
lumière et certaines personnes
aujourd'hui me disent mais on avait
dénombré différence sans du parti on
appuie son patient faire une force
au contraire ça a été un vrai handicap
et fait ça se symbolise ces deux lignes
souverainistes à côté identitaire de
l'autre se sont symbolisés danflous
philippot et philippe olivier
et ces deux hommes qui humainement plus
sympa et ben voilà ça ça fait des
étincelles et ça ça n'a pas marché
c'est peut-être ça aussi le problème
pendant la campagne alors qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous en dites
tout d'abord je suis juste je vais mener
sur un tout petit point
le philly politiques qui pour le verbe
est haut qu'on entende l'opposition est
stable peut-être mais je signale que
depuis qu'il a pris le réel on n'entend
absolument pas le front national n'est
absolument pas au dicton le dit y
compris dans l'opposition je suis la
parentèle donc il faut réfléchir à
l'efficacité de telle ou telle stratégie
oui l'arrivée je suis président je l'aï
leçon à sa montée en influence et une
vérité c'est le beau frère de marine le
pen c'est un ancien lieutenant de bruno
mégret
il était au front national il ya 25 ans
était parti il est revenu très
activement et il est clairement sur une
ligne qui n'est pas du tout celle pour
laquelle moi je suis venu mais je ne
crois même pas que cette ligne là
c'était celle à laquelle adhèrent
elle-même marine le pen et c'est ça
qu'on ne comprend pas on donne un
éclairage sur cette campagne
présidentielle on a pu sentir parfois
aussi des hésitations peut-être de
marine le pen
pourquoi il est revenu au temps on force
parce qu'il est revenu petit à petit ça
a mis des mois et des mois et pourquoi
pendant cette campagne
je crois d'ailleurs qu'il ya eu un dîner
c'est ce que j'ai vu dans la presse en
novembre 2016 vous
vous inquiétez du retour des mégrétistes
et marine le pen vous dit ne t'inquiète
pas qu'est-ce qui se passe
on comprend par là mais moi non plus
mais je n'en mets le très honnêtement je
suis dans la même incompréhension que
vous je vois effectivement un retour en
force de ces gens-là fin 2016
incarnée par cette figure du beau frère
qui a qu'un discours très identitaire
mais en même temps très européiste sire
que la mue actuelle du front national
qui est en train d'abandonner la
souveraineté nationale le fch exit etc
david en est qu à ses débuts parce que
lui je sais que ce qu'il dit ça va même
beaucoup plus loin il veut complètement
maintenir l'euro et l'union européenne
etc
et je crois qu'ils iront vers cela a
naturellement mais pour moi c'est
incompréhensible
mais ça crée de vrais problèmes pendant
la campagne présidentielle même si on
gère on gère il ya de très belles choses
qui sont faites aussi pendant cette
campagne
mais c'est vrai que moi je vois des
discours de plus en plus identitaire
civilisationnel je ne dis pas que ces
sujets doivent pas être traités
il ya des manières d'en parler et puis
il ya des façons aussi d'aborder
différents sujets quand vous ne parlait
quasiment plus que d'un seul sujet quels
sujets identitaires
bien évidemment vous perdez des gens en
août et alors il a quand même parlé de
l'euro on a l'impression qu'elle a
tâtonné leroy le retrait très peu mais
on peut parler de plein de choses on
peut parler des petits salaires des
petites retraites de santé d'écologie or
on en parlait très peu et en fin de
campagne nous retrouvions de plus en
plus de témoignages par mail par
courrier ou dans la rue tout simplement
de gens qui nous disaient qu'est ce que
vous dites sur les petits salaires
qu'est ce que vous dites sur les petites
retraites
on ne vous entend plus et ces gens-là
filet soit dans l'abstention je sois bon
choix je m'élance ans et ça pour vous
c'est moi je vais sortir les jeunes
venus en interne vous l'avais dit en
interne
et alors qu'est ce qu'elle a répondu
parce qu'on me parle beaucoup du débat
et on y reviendra mais là c'est ça donne
finalement une ambiance ça révèle une
des choses sur une ambiance était dit
comme ça comme un conseiller doit le
dire dans la campagne non ce n'était pas
audible en interne moment j'ai dit ça je
t'en prie ça n'a pas empêché marine le
pen d'expression d'être qualifiés au
second tour et après le franc cela c'est
surtout après la défaite du second tour
que le front national complètement
changé de voir ouais vraiment a épousé
cette ligne là voilà moi j'en ai fait le
constat je l'ait compris peu à peu est
ce que je suis
maintenant ça je suis parti mais dès le
lendemain vous lancez votre association
je te mangerais votre fils tant que les
patriotes donc on voit bien que quand
même vous dégainez assez rapidement bass
rec je dégaine moi c'était une démarche
très positive constructive
on nous dit on fait la refondation faut
faire parler tout le monde n'y a rien
qui est à bout je crée une structure
dédiée à cela et d'ailleurs vous
remarquerez qu avant le mois de
septembre quand marine le pen en parle
dans les médias elle dit c'est un film
tant que ça fait partie du débat de la
refondation c'est très bien ça pose pas
de problème c'est à partir de septembre
qu'ils honnissent tient peut-être
utiliser les patriotes comme un prétexte
supplémentaire puisque ou couscoussiers
tout lui pour le faire partout elle
pourquoi elle pourquoi elle change
d'avis sur vous à ce moment là pourquoi
elle se laisse entre guillemets entraîné
qu'est ce qui se passe je jacques je
crois que des cadres ont pris une
importance telle après la présidentielle
profitant de la faiblesse de marine le
pen du fait du débat notamment du débat
raté de second tour
ces gens là ont pris une importance
telle ils n'ont jamais été mariniste
fous de leur conviction qu'ils ont voulu
imposer définitivement leur ligne il a
dû être probablement dans la dans un
doute pendant quelques semaines et
quelques mois ne sachant pas trop et
puis finalement s'est rallié à cela mais
l'arrière fond soul et la trame de tout
ça c'est un changement d'objectif
fondamentale du front national vrai
avant la présidentielle l'objectif c'est
clairement la victoire
sinon moi je n'y aurais pas été ça ne
m'intéressait pas je suis moi je me bats
je fais la politique pour qu'on gagne
qu'on applique nos idées combat soit en
2017 et après la le second tour
l'objectif change et c'est un gestion de
rente électorale où ils se disent
probablement à raison vu comment ça se
passe on ne gagnera jamais on n'y
arrivera pas il faut sauver les meubles
il faut il faut gérer une rente
électorale pour sauver un maximum de
postes
et alors on va revenir mais concernant
marine le pen son père je me souviens un
moment disait que c'était une femme sous
influence mais à l'époque c'était sous
la vôtre quand il quand il était
brouillé avec sa fille alors est-ce
qu'il avait peut-être raison sur sa
psychologie finalement son père comme ça
moi j'en ai jamais dit ça non moi je
n'ai jamais dit ça moi j'ai vraiment
beaucoup plus responsable que cela je
n'aime pas dire que tu une femme sous
influence je la respecte beaucoup trop
jeudi qu'elle laisse faire si elle est
sûr c'est qu'elle est d'accord
donc moi je crois moi vous savez qui est
responsable
au final c'est toujours le chef est
alors il a dit aussi effectivement que
et vous l'avez dit aussi de
17 c'était la conquête dans votre esprit
aujourd'hui vous dit qu'elle le veut moi
et olivier faedy mais vous vous avez
toujours voulu ça finalement la conquête
et finalement si ce n'est pas avec le fn
c'est tout c'est tout seul c'est quelque
chose que vous aviez déjà décidé avant
finalement votre départ il était inscrit
comme il le commis le sous-entend non je
n'en pas du tout je n'aurais jamais
imaginé ça au mois de mai encore dernier
est même encore au probablement au mois
d'août dernier de partir comme cela et
faire autre chose maintenant nous avons
formé les patriotes c'est un mouvement
beaucoup plus moderne qui vise à être
beaucoup plus crédible est beaucoup plus
professionnelle et qui défendit les plus
ouvertes même si je suis lucide c'est
pas facile de monter un mouvement
politique je sais très bien tout cela
mais je pense que c'est toujours
préférable à faire de la politique
alimentaire on reste tout simplement
pour rester et dans l'espoir d'être
redditionnelle plus professionnelle
c'est à dire que le fn n'est pas
professionnel il ya eu un effort moi je
suis arrivé le front avec déjà 40 ans
d'existence était un gros party
tribunicien il ya eu un vrai fort de
professionnalisation ça avance et ça
jamais été totalement comme il fallait
quand même y avait toujours des
persistances mais c'est là que j'ai
peut-être été un peu naïf il est il a
été un peu rattrapé par ses vieux démons
et dans ses vieux démons
il n'y a pas que de l'idéologie il ya
aussi un fonctionnement un peu clanique
est un peu un peu désorganisé et pas
très professionnel
alors peut-être le retour de philippe
olivier ces deux clans dont la famille
est le beau frère il ya un
fonctionnement clanique sastre je dis
pas qu'il ya que des gens du clan
certainement pas j'en mettais une preuve
il y en a d'autres mais il ya un
fonctionnement à la base du fait de la
construction de ce parti qui est
clanique et le tanit est incompatible
avec une professionnalisation durable et
même avec un élargissement durable en
réalité vous pouvez quand même sens jean
marie ça reste un club
oui mais je rejoins moi je dis pas à une
peine égale jean marie le pen ce serait
trop simple
mais je dis que là peut-être que j'ai
été naïf j'ai cru qu'on pourrait
vraiment le changer totalement en fait
on ne change pas totalement il revient
quand même un peu comme il était alors
vous avez évoqué les hésitations sur la
ligne et c'est vrai il ya quelque chose
d'assez symbolique 1 c'est effectivement
cette affiche de campagne qu'ils étaient
lens et c'était bien avant la
présidentielle en 2016 ça début 2016
voilà la france apaisée ça je crois que
c'était un peu votre votre désir de 7,2
cette communication effectivement apaisé
et puis un changement de pied pendant la
campagne avec une stratégie beaucoup
plus virulente qui s'est incarné lors du
fameux débat on revoit un petit extrait
vous faciliter une fois de plus de la
vie des grandeurs vous vous êtes dans
vos amis dans l'assignation cse et qui
vous buvez déco à la rotonde
en somme selon madame le pen pour alstom
vous avez dit à du monsieur
dupont-aignan
c'est pas moi mais où parle d' alstom
janvier 2015 devant l'assemblée j'ai
pris la décision de permettre à general
écrits de renvoi la personne madame le
pen vous ne parlez pas du lendemain le
nord les d'alstom et general electric
laissez-moi terminée une autre leçon
togneri des leçons de monsieur
montebourg
vous avez accordé alors qu'ils le
refusaient la vente de sfr et c'est la
réalité pourquoi vous l'assumez pas je
l'assumé je laisserai aux fesses lemieux
de défaut cds en mai les prises et de
faire des fusions acquisitions ça vous
savez très bien même il ya aucun
problème vous êtes en train de lire une
fiche qui ne correspond pas au dossier
que vous avez cités c'est triste pour
vous parce que ça montre votre
impréparation à nos concitoyens
voilà et ce soir-là à une caméra était
présente dans la loge de l'équipe macron
et elle montre que dès cet instant le
camp adverse comprend mieux de dvd en
maîtrise et de faire des fusions
voilà et là ils se disent elle a perdu
on a gagné enfin ce débat en tout cas et
c'est philippot qui la coache
moi j'ai toujours préparé pendant des
années toutes les émissions de fond avec
marine le pen mais sur le fond je suis
vidé on est deux personnalités
politiques avoir fait un débat avec
macron jusqu'ici à marine le pen est à
moi moi j'étais le premier je l'avais
fait en 2015 c'était sur france 2
chacun pourra retrouver l'extrait j'ai
fait un débat de fond voilà après ce qui
s'est passé pendant le débat même ça et
beaucoup d'autres débats je ne sais pas
là aussi j'ai un point d'interrogation
mais je n'ai pas été de ceux qui ont
accablé marine le pen après j'ai même
fait mois le service après vente dès le
soir même sur les en duplex pour
absolument l'air je vous propose qu'on
revoit on revoit les images pour les
téléspectateurs
j'ai trouvé excellente et je les
trouvais très éclairante jusqu'ici
monsieur macron avait réussi à passer
entre les gouttes en faisant croire
qu'il était nouveau et marine le pen l'a
rappelé aux français parce que c'est
nécessaire quand même pour savoir à qui
on va confier éventuellement les clés du
pays qui était totalement le candidat
sortant soutenu par tout le gouvernement
le président de la république sortant
voilà donc effectivement là vous faites
le service après vente est en fait vous
mentez oui mais quel est mon rôle
samedi à trois jours du vote je suis
dans l'équipe de campagne son vice
président qu'est-ce que je dois dire sur
les plateaux de télé qu'elle a été très
mauvaise et que est catastrophique vous
avez dit après coup oui mais je dois
dire ça bien sûr que non j'ai une
loyauté à défendre donc je sais de
limiter la casse en disant des choses
dont je sais que
elles sont pas forcément perçue comme
très crédible mais je sais mon rôle
voilà c'est mon rôle
ça n'empêche que j'ai une lucidité sur
ce débat voilà là vous dites et je sais
qu'il a été ratée je ne sais pas
pourquoi mais je pense que ce qui a été
encore plus raté finalement c'est la
gestion de l'après présidentielle à
l'arago là on commence à ouvrir des
grands débats sur l'union européenne
l'euro en pleine législatif qui est
insensé et puis on commence à
déstructurer complètement programme du
front national est un leurre rétrécir
sur ce qu'ils appellent les fondamentaux
c'est à dire on ne parle quasiment plus
que d'immigration
on ne fait pas un programme simplement
sur l'immigration même si c'est un sujet
est alors justement pour revenir sur ce
débat mme on vous l'avait effectivement
après coup juger je cite catastrophique
car c'est ce que vous avez dit
catastrophique
et pourquoi vous dites ou point
d'interrogation là vous venez dire point
d'interrogation sur ce débat ça veut
dire quoi vous coachez marine le pen
il ya eu un article d'ailleurs dans le
coach mais voilà qui qui qui raconte que
le matin elle a une migraine oculaire
qu'elle est en état visiblement de
stress intense
ça veut dire quoi qu'est ce qui s'est
passé moi je rentre pas dans les détails
médicaux parce que c'est là dedans elle
est ce que ce n'est pas totalement
anormal qu'elle soit stressé maintenant
c'est une professionnelle a l'habitude
donc je n'ai pas compris
voilà je moi j'étais en loge j'ai vu le
débat à la télévision en les retours
d'image je n'ai pas compris je peux pas
vous dire plus que ça ça veut dire que
vous vous aviez préparé un débat avec
elle et qu'en parallèle on avait préparé
un autre avec quelqu'un d'autre et
qu'elle a été sur une nouvelle stratégie
- j étais le matin je ne sais pas qui
elle a vu l'après midi mais encore une
fois je pense est elle-même au moins ne
ne le fait pas il faut pas fuir ses
responsabilités la seule personne au
bout d'un moment qui responsable dans un
débat c'est vous même
l'erreur c'est quoi du coup qu'en
revoyant ces images d'erreur c'est quoi
c'était des trappes agressive
oui c'est pas ce n'était pas le registre
que les gens attendaient d'une élection
présidentielle de quelqu'un qui prétend
à la magistrature suprême où on attend
certains auteurs une certaine hauteur
une certaine capacité à rassurer
rassembler et à être surtout sur le fond
de son propre programme à soit pas sur
celui de son adversaire tout le temps
mais c'est tout mais je suis pas là dans
un sur un ton péremptoire à dire à
marine le pen ce cadeau a dû faire moi
je dis ce que je leur ai fait moi et ça
dit quoi
dit que peut-être elle ne désire pas
réellement le pouvoir ce choix de
stratégie je me méfie toujours ses
analyses parapsychologiques ou politico
psychologique autant je ne suis pas sûr
qu'on puisse savoir faire de grandes
démonstrations sur deux heures et demie
de débat on peut constater un échec
après démontrer les choses c'est
compliqué par contre ce qui est évident
c'est ce qui s'est passé après les mois
qui ont suivi sont des mois qui ont
démontré que le front national ne visait
plus pouvoir et que le front national ne
visait plus à dire la vérité c'est être
encore pire à dire la vérité à ses
électeurs bas d'hier on peut faire vous
l'avez montré tout à l'heure on peut
faire plein de choses faire un
formidable même dans l'union européenne
et dans l'euro
alors que ça fait dix ans qu'on essaie
de démontrer d'un verre ce à raison a
raison mais moi je n'ai pas abandonné
ses idées c'est quand même un rapport
particulier à la vérité oui en tout cas
il ya un vrai changement de discours
après où est la vérité en tout cas si le
changement de discours c'est sûr
alors on a parlé des choses qui se sont
cassés pendant la campagne
un petit peu aussi des choses qui se
sont cassés entre vous et marine le pen
quelques semaines après votre rupture
elle parlait de la refondation sur le
plateau de france 2 et elle dressait
votre portrait en termes peu flatteurs
je crois qu'il ne souhaitait pas cette
refondation vous savez la féministe vous
savez d'avoir affaibli les noms savait
que la refondation ça nécessite quand
même d'avoir du courage de l'humilité
aussi la capacité de se remettre en
cause et je pense que tout le monde n'a
pas la force d'âme d'accepter ce
processus le départ de floch ils peuvent
faire revenir des gens chez nous avez
vous déclaré à la voix du nord qui par
exemple
écoutez je pense que quand on a un poste
aussi important que vice prise en charge
de la stratégie et de la communication
on est un peu celui qui décide qui a le
droit de parler et qui n'a pas le droit
de parler
je pense qu'il ya énormément de gens
autour de nous d'experts
d'universitaires de magistrats de
professionnels dans leur domaine de
compétence qui n'ont peut-être pas pu
exprimer leurs positions qui étaient
muselés par coeur
disons que florian avait plutôt raison
est que tous ceux qui n'étaient pas
d'accord avec lui était plutôt considéré
comme ayant tort vous avez les faits
donc en réalité j'avais laissé fallait
peut-être j'ai une part de
responsabilité voilà ce que vous
reconnaissez dans ce portrait non mais
là j'avoue que ça me fait presque rire
ben j'imagine la scène où j'arrive en
réunion devant toi tu peux parler toi tu
peux pas parler et marine le pen qui
dirait choisi pour tous a d'abord manqué
un peu de crédibilité
deuxièmement je les attends et vous même
j'imagine comme journaliste vous les
attendez tous ces personnalités
reconnues et compétents dans leur
domaine qui soi-disant étaient muselés
par ma présence et qui maintenant vous
pouvoir s'exprimer allègrement ça fait
plus d'un mois que fait partie je les ai
toujours pas vu et alors elle se sent
attiré justement peut-être sur ces
problèmes et après que je me suis je me
sois mis des gens à dos que parfois j'ai
manqué diplomatie très probablement
c'est à la base pas tout à fait mon
caractère je manque de diplomatie j'en
suis le conscient c'est quelque chose
que je dois améliorer mes chez un peu
passionné parfois dans mes idées quitte
à avancer en mode un peu bulldozer mais
ça j'en suis conscient mais j'ai
peut-être blesser inutilement des gens
je suis parfaitement prêt à le
reconnaître
alors on a écouté marine le pen je
voulais vous faire écouter aussi un
petit complément de d'olivier faille que
je trouvais justement intéressant comme
complément enfin philippe ont incarné
c'est à dire un homme venu de la gauche
déjà ça passe mal un homosexuel
évidemment aussi
moi j'ai entendu plein de fois d
base parfois même des cadres me faire
des remarques homophobes pas directement
propos de philippe home et de son
entourage
ça c'est une évidence existe et aussi
son attitude c'est évident c'est vrai
qu'elle est une île et froid parfois une
dit pas bonjour dans les bureaux
répartis dans des couloirs
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui a été
maintes fois racontée est décrit est
donc on va dire que c'est un assemblage
de choses à la fois ce qu'il incarne et
à la fois sur l'attitude si je dis
bonjour désolé j'ai été instruits comme
ça mais mes parents étaient instituteurs
dans l'école publique mais j'imagine que
le disou bruyamment aujourd'hui parmi
ceux qui sont restés là bas mais ça
c'est totalement faux et sur ce que vous
incarnez ce qu'il est ce qu'il vient de
dire parce que ça vous n'en parlez pas
quand vous y étiez mais aujourd'hui
justement est ce que et ça ça a pu ça
peut être je moi je distingue toujours
le le peuple militant que j'ai vu chaque
semaine je moi je
contrairement aux siennes les ondes j'ai
toujours été extrêmement connecter avec
la base de l'appareil la base du front
national puisque jallet chaque semaine
faire des réunions publiques des
meetings des déjeuners de digne des
beaujolais des crêpes des secours et les
chandler de l'étouffer et à grand
plaisir dans tout les coins de france et
j'ai jamais eu ce genre de remarques de
la part de militants on dirait peut-être
que ceux qui pensent ça ne venait pas
mais je sache je ne laisserai pas je ne
laisserai pas les insulte vis-à-vis
d'eux parce que j'en ai entendu trop d'
insulte et j'ai pas vu cette réalité
sont 1 après les cadres intermédiaires
qui étaient là depuis très longtemps et
qui ont peut-être pas été assez
renouveler ce qui était aussi un autre
problème ou des cadres supérieurs même
oui ça doit exister homophobie
il doit y en avoir un peu vrai mais il y
en a dans la société française mais on
va peut-être un peu je sais pas j'en ai
jamais si vous voulez fait un cheval de
bataille pour me valoriser moi même
certaines banques partenaires vous en
avais jamais parlé c'est pour ça que
quand vous pose la crise assurant qu'il
y avait des propos y compris parfois de
le cadre supérieur du mouvement d'un
salt d'après vos confrères qui me le
rapporter des propos qui étaient pas
très glorieux pour ceux qui détenaient
et vous faisait rien dans ces cas là
vous ne réagissez pas non j'aurais
peut-être dû j'aurais peut-être dû aller
les voir mais mais en même temps je
craignais beaucoup que ce soit
instrumentalisée dans le sens où il
essaie d'en jouer où il essaie de se
victimiser ou quoi que ce soit je suis
pas du tout dans cette démarche là mais
j'aurais peut-être vu et vous dit marine
le pen n'a pas assez renouveler les
cadres intermédiaires
finalement j'aurais lagarde et
fonctionnement peut-être qu'annick vous
l'avez dit elle a pas renouveler les
cadres non mais beaucoup a été fait mais
mais très loin d'être c'est très loin
d'être suffisant voilà c'est tout je
pense qu'il aurait fallu tout changer en
fait il aurait fallu tout changé quand
elle a pris le parti en 2011 le nom ne
pas créer présidence d'honneur voilà et
puis renouvelée intégralement son bureau
politique renouvelée énormément ses
cadres locaux départementaux et
probablement que ça a tardé parce que
justement il y avait encore la
présidence d'honneur très puissante
encore elle a passé difficile de l'ombre
elle a une peur de rompre avec son père
s'il y avait une difficulté après je
suis pas sa place mais moi je pense que
c'était la fenêtre de tir elle était là
bon bah merci beaucoup
florian philippot pour remercier pour ce
retour et cette projection dans l'avenir
on va vous laisser quitter ce votre
bureau alors ça l'est un petit peu je
reprends mes outils alors
[Musique]